Facebook is revamping its targeted  advertisements after settling lawsuits  with civil rights groups social media  site is now changing ad targeting  systems to try to stop discrimination in  housing credit and employment ads  companies will no longer be able to  target people based on age gender or zip  code the goal is to prevent  discrimination based on race ethnicity  sexual orientation religion and other  legally protected categories Facebook  CEO Sheryl Sandberg says the changes  quote mark an important step in our  broader effort to prevent discrimination  and promote fairness and inclusion on  Facebook Facebook is still facing  government investigations over its data  sharing and privacy practices